hey guys welcome to another episode of
my flipping to billion Series where I'm
going to try to get to 1 billion coins
using the grand exchange only we're
starting at 50 mil from the last episode
and uh thanks again for all the support
on that one uh I did really well uh if
we could definitely go ahead and toss
this video like if you are enjoying it
that would be greatly appreciated uh so
last episode we started at about 50 mil
and we ended at about 59 mil so but a 9
mil profit not too bad uh we're gonna
try to stay on a upward trend of getting
a uh larger amount of money per episode
uh cuz somebody left a comment and said
well if you go at this rate
exponentially you should be done in 17
episodes so I don't think that's going
to happen but we'll give it a try so
we're going to start off this episode by
uh buying some more of the Eternal gems
this one has been an extremely good flip
quite a few times uh it fluctuates in
price a lot so it tends to give really
good margin so we'll do four of those
next up we're just doing in a rims armor
set combination this is always a very
good set combination uh so we're going
to go ahead and just buy 10 maybe of
each piece and combine it and you can
usually get about a millon profit off of
doing 10 of these so we're going to toss
in 10 Rim staffs and we have the rest in
already and last up I'm going to toss in
a third age amulet seems like it went
from 8 mil to 11 mil all in one go and
it just fluctuates a lot in price so I
think this could give us a very good
margin especially since I'm going to be
away for a day or two uh items like
these are really good to leave in when
you have a lot of spare time or time
you're not going to be around at your
computer uh so we'll go ahead and put uh
well I guess we'll just do one of these
cuz that's all we can afford okay so
actually was not that long and all the
rims armor sets sold off nice and clean
uh all 10 came through no problem and we
sold them off I think for about a 100K
profit on each one we'll go and
calculate the total amount but I think
it's around a m we would have made in
total uh we also bought all the Eternal
gems those have yet to sell uh but they
will hopefully eventually so
24490 minus all the cost should give us
about 1 mil and minus the last piece
here and it's going to be 1,0 192k not
bad okay so I'm going to put an offer in
for the team Cape X this is actually a
free to-play item that's really good to
flip has about a 150k margin on it and
for whatever reason these actually buy a
lot quicker than you might imagine uh so
we're going to put an offering for 1525
and we'll go for 10 uh next up we're
actually going to be doing a Darkness uh
page flip so we're going to be doing the
similar uh similar thing to the a rim
set except we're going to be using
ancient Pages uh they do come through a
little bit slower but it did have a very
good margin on it so we'll go ahead and
give it a try and drop it down for the
ancient page 4 is the last one we got to
do uh the one thing that is a bit of a
drawback from these is it takes up a lot
of your offer slots so if you are for
whatever reason only flipping to One
account and you don't have a lot of
offer slots these can take up a lot of
them uh but they can definitely be worth
it as well so we're going to put an
offer in for the last page here for
about 157 and 15 and and hopefully these
will buy overnight and last up we're
going to give the third age amulet
another try it didn't end up buying at
the last price so we'll go ahead and try
to buy two more of them okay so we're
back and we had a couple good flips but
also a couple of flops uh the Flop being
uh well mostly the third age amulet uh
but also the Eternal gem didn't do that
well I think we actually broke even on
the Eternal gem so that's not too bad um
but the uh amulets ended up losing 161k
on each one so about 322k in total uh
but on the team Cape X's we actually
profited about 700k uh 728 to be exact
uh which is pretty good as well as we do
have the ancient Pages almost all sold
off okay so we're going to do the team
Cape X again it just worked pretty well
last time so why not uh repeat the feat
again and we'll try buying them for 15
uh 45 and maybe sell them for upwards of
1,600 if we're lucky and uh we're going
to do another 10 uh Darkness page flips
uh seems to still have about 100K margin
on them uh which is pretty good for how
cheap they are considering right now
it's about 98k so we'll do another 10
and hopefully we can get another mil out
of that okay and once again we're going
to do the Eternal gem uh actually
fluctuates from 5400 to 7 mil so we're
going to try buying them for
5501 and you can see the graph here like
look at that that could be an amazing
flip if it pans out properly and I think
we'll just invest quite a bit of money
here I guess pretty much all our money
yeah seven that'll be all our money and
will come back when some items have sold
okay we have a bunch of flips coming in
uh two of the book of Darkness page
flips have uh completed now the first
one we did a while ago we actually only
got a 54k margin on each book we did 15
of them uh which gives us about
810k uh flip in total the second set did
a lot better for the margin at least
131k on each one and we only did 10 that
time but we got 1.3 mil of that um we
did some team Cape X's uh for actually
304k margin on each one which is amazing
608k uh from that and uh the last thing
we did here was the dragon Defender
ornament kit which we got a 83k margin
on and four of those gave us a 330k
profit so not bad okay so the first item
I'm looking at now is actually the Ring
of stone I have never flipped this item
before however I have flipped the Ring
of nature in the ring of coins a few
times uh so this is looking pretty
promising and it's actually a lot
cheaper than the rest of them I think
this only comes in at about 2 mil
although I have to double check here uh
yeah about 2 mil and it looks like it
has about a 150k margin on it so we'll
try buying uh from about 1.8 mil each
and uh we'll sell them for maybe1 1950
or something and we'll go for I'll go
for eight for now uh the obsidian armor
set is something I flipped right on
launch day and it was really good uh now
it seems like the volume of them traded
has dropped dramatically but the margin
is about 150k as well as we we'll give
that item a try never tried it uh since
the day it came out but we'll go ahead
and do maybe eight or nine of those as
well try buying them for about uh 34 85
or something like that and yeah we'll do
10 and I think last we're going to do
another armor set the uh Samurai Dragon
headset very cheap and has about an 80k
mergin on it which is not as good but we
only have about 10 mil left uh to invest
here uh so about 605k we'll try buying
them for and we'll see if these armor
sets end up working they're not traded a
lot uh so we'll probably have to wait a
while to completely flip these all right
we got a couple dead flips coming in
here the Eternal uh Crystal we ended up
buying but really didn't give us any
margin on it only about 9k uh so 27k
flip there uh pretty terrible uh the
obsidian armor sets were the only good
flip at about 112k margin each one
giving us about 560k which is still good
we didn't actually lose money and The
Zing kits actually gave us about 170k in
profit so not terrible okay so I think
we're going to do a guthan armor set
combination we have all 10 of them in
here and we already bought seven of the
plate bodies so far and it looks like
has about 120k margin next up I'm going
to try the free to-play item the hill
giant club uh for whatever reason a huge
increase in price in the last couple of
days I'm not quite sure what that might
be about but uh we'll go ahead and try
10 of these uh next up we're going to
try the Dragon Sword I haven't flipped
this for a while but it's already down
to 1 mil I bought one of these for like
15 mil when raids came out uh obviously
glad didn't hang on to that too long but
we'll go ahead and put them in for about
11:32 and we'll do something similar uh
at about eight of these if we can afford
it nope looks like just seven and we'll
be back in a little while so once again
the gothan armor set ended up uh to be a
very good flip we got about 100K on each
one giving us about a m in profit in
total uh which is really nice uh the
Dragon Sword we only managed to get
about a 40K margin on so 200k in profit
off of that not terrible unfortunately
the hill giant club and we ended up
buying way too high and it crashed down
a bit we only ended up losing about uh
35k on each club we have one to sell
still but we'll probably lose close to
300K and total off that item not great
but it could have been worse okay so
we're just about to head to bed so we're
actually going to put an offer in for 20
of a TS combination uh so hopefully
these will actually buy overnight uh cuz
they don't actually buy that quickly but
uh well we'll see so once again we're
going to be doing the Eternal gem it
says on G tracker that has roughly a
500K margin on it and this item just
will not stop fluctuating in price so
we'll try buying some overnight cuz why
not and I think we're going to maybe
leave a little bit room for one more
item to buy but we'll maybe buy them for
about uh 6480 or something around there
and we'll do maybe four or five of them
so we only had about uh 6 mil left to
spend and I just thought I might as well
invest that money and we're going to try
to buy the SAR doans tier H never
flipped this item before but it looks
like it has about a 200k margin uh which
is pretty good for the price and we'll
try buying it for about 5.5 mil
hopefully we can sell it for maybe 5.8
mil if we're lucky and we'll just dump
the rest of our money which is going to
be uh I guess just three quantity and
we'll be back in the morning okay I
apologize for how messy my granic change
is right now and a couple of the items I
was trying to buy didn't come through at
all uh but what did end up uh working
was the TX equipment now we bought them
at so many different price points I went
and calculated it and we ended up
getting a 54k margin on each one and we
did 15 sets one was actually just a
price check as that's a 820k profit
which is still really good the guilded
boots were really surprising we only
flipped four of them but we got a
269k margin on each one giving this just
over a mill in profit at
176k uh so I'm really happy with how
that went even though
ended up being very messy so once again
I'm going to be trying the hill giant
club I'm not really sure why I ended up
doing this as this a recorded in post I
can't really go back and uh change my uh
decision again but we'll try buying them
for 1275 and I guess I'm just hoping
that we can sell it for that
1400 Mark but I don't really know the
reason why these are fluctuating so much
so it's not a really smart investment
but I'm doing it anyway I guess okay
another item I haven't done in a while
is the torture ornament kit which always
gets me with how little the Binum is on
this one it appears to be four so we'll
have to test that but uh we're going to
try buying them for maybe 160 170k
margin uh which is okay for the price
point but I could really find a better
item but we'll just dump the rest of our
money in here I think and it's call it a
day okay so pretty much every single
item uh was a very good flip a very good
investment um the best one by far was
the uh book of law combination flip uh
we ended up getting a 180k margin on
each one uh giving us a 1.8 mil profit
off the item which is really good
especially for how expensive the item is
just a mill or something for that uh
next up we flip the um Hill giant club
for a 61k margin uh 488k in profit off
of that uh the torture ornament kit we
got a 95k margin on so 380k for there in
the fury we ended up getting 600k in
profit almost so in total if we
calculate that everything
combined we got about 3.2 mil in profit
off of that flip bring this all the way
up to 70 mil in total so next upep I'm
going to be doing another um Darkness
page flip we got 15 in we're going to
leave it in overnight and hopefully we
can do uh something just as profitable
as the book of law next up is the
infinity hat had I've had some pretty
good luck with this item in the past uh
right now we're going to probably try to
flip 10 of them for about a um let's see
3872 and actually looks like it has a
200k margin on it right now uh which is
pretty good we'll try buy them for 3875
and do 10 of them another item I've had
some pretty good luck with in the past
is the ring of coins uh it's actually a
freeo play item if you didn't know uh
one of the most or if not the most
expensive free-to-play item and we're
going to try buying them for about 17.1
mil uh so once again the uh book
combinations ended up being very messy I
bought them at different price points
ended up selling some backs they just
weren't coming through the price was
tanking so overall we ended up making
37k on each uh set combination and we
only did 10 so about 370k there now the
Ring of coins only gave us a 69k margin
but something really exciting is
actually managed to buy you can see
right there two of them for 16.1 mil and
I'm hoping to sell them for something
similar to what I just sold the last one
at which is over a mil in profit it
should be on each ring uh which is
really EX in uh the hats uh or sorry the
infinity hat we only get 100K on nothing
too good there but really excited over
the Rings okay so we're going to put an
offering for the books of Darkness just
a nice cheap uh mid-range item I do a
lot same thing for the gloves of
Darkness I'm just straight up price
checking it cuz why not uh has about a
uh 32k margin on it so we'll do 10 why
not and uh we'll just complete it off
with the robe top of Darkness honestly
don't even really care if this has a
good margin or not probably just going
going to do it anyway uh 334k into uh
306 and that's still about a 28k margin
so not terrible and we'll do 10 of these
as well okay so I actually did manage to
sell the Ring of coins for a
1,117 k margin on each one or 2.2 mil in
profit uh probably the biggest margin
I've had on an item in quite a while so
really happy with that uh we got some
reasonable good flips on the darkness
sets as well uh 240 in profit off the
boots 124k off the gloves and 250k off
the top uh and that's where I'm going to
end up for today guys I hope you enjoyed
the video and we actually made quite a
bit of profit if we have a look at our
total cash tack it looks like it's at
about uh 73 mil and we started the
episode at about 60 mil uh so we'll go
ahead and just have a look at that in
our inventory screen here so add that in
and it looks like we're at actually
closer to 74 mil so 14 mil in profit off
of Just this one episode uh so we
continue at this raid uh we should be
reaching one bill if we keep on the
exponential path not sure if that's
going to happen or not but anyway if you
did enjoy the episode don't forget to
toss the video a like and I will see you
guys in episode number three
[Music]
oh